biggest pet peeves like okay first of
all of course playing to good is one
thing and like smiling without a reason
this year this really dries McCree there
are some players who sometimes during
the game start to smile without any
reason I can like comprehend I don't
think that because if if they knew that
would be very easy to drag me out of
control I don't think it can be anything
but it's just I don't I don't think it's
exactly one thing that that would be too
easy any repetitive noise is awful like
for tapping and playing with pieces like
we're very repetitively although some so
that's weird like something that annoys
me and some of it doesn't when it comes
to playing with pieces but yeah like
repetitive noises are the worst I don't
know why but those just really get in
your head
certain players who you know get up all
the time and move a lot and go to the
bathroom and come back and then go again
it's a bit annoying but yeah I'm fine
but maybe when if my opponent cops too
much on the board or sneezes a lot on
the board that but without using a tisha
that can get really annoying if I if I
had to pick one thing I think it would
actually be it would be what what liván
or rowing does its board sometimes you
know you like leans back and stretches
out kind of like this and and I feel
it's a little bit exaggerated sometimes
so you know if I had to pick a pet
people would be that because that's the
only thing that I can think of amongst
top players that really stands out